es ist wieder diese Zeit im Monat wo wir
ganz viele Gemüse Samen nehmen und in
unseren Aussaatschalen im Haus vorziehen
wir gehen auch gleich raus und sehen
direkt ins Bett aus wir pflanzen
gemüsepflänzchen nach draußen und ich
zeige euch in diesem Video welche
Gemüsepflanzen jetzt im Mai an der Reihe
sind der Mai ist einer der spannendsten
Monate im Gemüsegarten nicht nur weil
wir jede Menge gemüsepflänzchen aussehen
können und auch nach draußen ins Bett
raus Pflanzen können sondern auch wenn
wir den Mai einmal in der Mitte
durchschneiden müssen das heißt wir
denken in zwei Zeiträumen einmal vom
ersten bis 15 Mai also die Zeit vor den
Eisheiligen und dann die Zeit nach den
Eisheiligen dazu erzähle ich euch gleich
noch mehr jetzt starten wir erstmal mit
der Anzucht im Haus und ich zeige euch
welche gemüsepflänzchen ihr jetzt im
Haus in Töpfchen aussehen könnt und dann
gehen wir raus in den Garten und ich
zeige euch was jetzt in den beten
ansteht und es macht sich komisch
anhören aber so langsam ist es an der
Zeit dass wir auch an die Wintergemüse
denken deswegen habe ich hier jetzt auch
eine ganze Menge unterschiedlicher
Wintergemüse die man jetzt im Haus
vorziehen sollte damit man im Winter
immer noch ernten kann das sind zum
Beispiel der Grünkohl der palmenkohl
oder schwarzkohl falls ihr noch nie
schwarzkohl angebaut oder gegessen habt
macht das mal das ist so ein
kulinarisches Erlebnis ich werde jetzt
ein paar grünkohlpflanzen im Haus
vorziehen aber ich bin echt ein bisschen
am Haar dann mit mir weil wir im Juli
umziehen und dann noch keine fertig
gemachten Beete haben am neuen Hof also
da muss ich erstmal ganz schön viel
Arbeit über den Winter reinstecken und
kann dann erst nächstes Frühjahr wieder
anfangen zu gärtnern und dadurch gibt es
nicht so viel Sinn für mich gerade
Wintergemüse auszusehen aber ich habe
schon ein neues Bild angelegt vielleicht
pflanzlich einfach ganz viel da rein ich
weiß es noch nicht aber irgendwie kann
ich gerade nicht anders als trotzdem was
vorzuziehen vielleicht fällt mir ja noch
irgendeine Lösung ein hier wachsen
übrigens in meiner Aussage schon ein
paar borutschpflanzen ich hoffe die
irritieren euch nicht zu doll die müssen
auch bald nach draußen umziehen aber der
Rest der Schale war noch frei und
deswegen sehe ich jetzt die neuen
Pflanzen einfach dazu ihr könnt jetzt
auch Lauch aussäen ich habe mich da
dagegen entschieden schon länger her
wegen des Umzugs was ist total sinnlos
ist bei warum sehe ich denn jetzt
Grünkohl aus aber kein Lauch und dann
kommt noch der Wirsing in die Erde den
habe ich zwar auch schon in einem der
anderen Monate vorgezogen aber wenn man
jeden Monat ein bisschen was aussieht
dann hat man eine versetzte Ernte also
dann wird nicht alles auf einmal reif
und das ist ja auch ganz praktisch wenn
wir gerade beim Kohlgemüse sind dann
erzähle ich euch noch vom Weißkohl und
vom Rotkohl die gehen nämlich auch jetzt
beide ich habe nur gerade so viele Beete
damit voll stehen dass ich die diesen
Monat mal auslasse aber meine lieblings
weißkohlsorte ist die Sorte türkis jetzt
für die Jahreszeit das variiert auch ein
bisschen früher im Jahr würde ich eine
andere Sorte auswählen die schneller
wächst damit meine erste Ernte hat und
die sollte türkis ist dann z.B auch gut
für die Sauerkraut Herstellung meine
lieblings rotkrautsorte ist die Sorte
Granat die ist auch sehr hübsch die
ganzen Kohlgemüse bedecke ich so
ungefähr 1 bis 2 cm mit Erde hier kommt
noch ein weiteres Kohlgemüse der Ferrari
da sehe ich auch wieder die Sorte aus
die jetzt auch in unserer Saatgut Box
drin war heißt azu ist da eine lila
farbene Sorte eine andere Sorte dich
auch sehr gerne mag ist die Sorte super
Schmelz die Macht grüne Knollen sehr
große auch zarte Knollen die sollte als
du es da ist noch ein bisschen hübscher
und fast genauso ertragreich genauso
zart super
ich habe mir noch einen cool hier
hingelegt das ist der Blumenkohl den
kann man jetzt auch noch Aussehen ich
habe aber so viel Blumenkohl und auch
Brokkoli da würde ich euch die Seite
kalinaro empfehlen den könnt ihr jetzt
auch aussehen aber ich lass die auch
beide diesen Monat mal aus weil es
langsam reicht hier ist ein Gemüse dass
ich letztes Mal vergessen habe das ist
die Zucchini ich weiß nicht ich glaube
ich habe die im April Video vergessen
dabei ist der April eigentlich der
perfekte Monat um die auszusehen also
meine Lieblingsseite ist die Zelle von
Tripolis und ab Mitte Mai könnt ihr die
als Freiland sehen und da sind wir auch
bei dem Thema über das ich sprechen
wollte das sind die Eisheiligen ach Mist
ich muss kurz die andere ausfahrtschale
holen
die Eisheiligen sind ein Zeitraum Mitte
Mai wo noch die letzten Fröste auftreten
könnten weil es so ein paar Frostbeulen
gibt wie zum Beispiel die Zucchini
Pflanzen die Gurken Paprika Auberginen
Tomaten muss man mit diesen ganzen
Gemüsepflanzen ich werde euch hier meine
Liste ein noch warten bis die
Eisheiligen vorbei sind bevor die nach
draußen gesät oder gepflanzt werden
können die meisten davon pflanzt man
aber zum Beispiel die Zucchini könnt ihr
Mitte Mai auch noch mal direkt ins
Freiland aussehen das ist sogar ganz
sinnvoll weil Zucchini Pflanzen oft von
mehltaube fallen werden und wenn ihr
dann noch meine zweite ausatmacht habt
ihr Pflanzen in verschiedenen
Altersstadien und die Jüngeren Pflanzen
stecken den Mehltau noch viel besser weg
als die älteren die geben zwar eine
spätere Ernte aber ihr habt ja schon
eine andere Pflanze die dann fleißig
Früchte produziert und wenn die Pflanze
dann befallen ist habt ihr Nachwuchs von
einer jüngeren Sorte die dann anfängt
Früchte zu bilden so könnt ihr dann bis
in den Herbst hinein noch bei Zucchini
ernten auch wenn der Mehltau mal richtig
doll zuschlagen sollte aber was halt
ganz wichtig ist ist dass ihr die ganzen
Frostbeulen der gemüsewelt erst nach den
Eisheiligen nach draußen setzt und dann
denkt auch daran dass ihr
gemüsepflänzchen immer auch abhärten
solltet bevor sie ins Beet umziehen weil
die ganzen jungen Pflanzen die man jetzt
im Haus vorzieht die sind ja noch gar
nicht anders raue Leben draußen im Beet
gewohnt da gibt's ein paar Probleme
einmal kennen die es noch gar nicht das
Wind über die Blätter streicht deswegen
ist es auch ganz gut wenn man seine
Jungpflänzchen bei der Anzucht immer mal
ein bisschen streichelt so dass dies
gewohnt sind die bewegt werden an den
Blättern also dass sie ein bisschen
stabileren Stängel dann auch bilden
außerdem sind die ja noch gar nicht ein
Temperaturunterschiede zwischen Tag und
Nacht gewohnt und vor allem kennen die
gar keinen Sonnenlicht auf ihrem
Blättern die kennen ja nur das Licht das
durch die Fenster gefiltert reinfällt
oder wenn ihr unter ansucht Lampen
vorzieht das Licht der Anzucht Lampen
und deswegen ist es eben wichtig dass
wir die erst langsam als draußen leben
schön das heißt man stellt die immer mal
so ein paar Stunden nach draußen und
dann wieder rein dann vielleicht mal zum
ersten Mal eine Stunde ins direkte
Sonnenlicht davor hat man sie vielleicht
nur in den Schatten gestellt und dann
stellt man sie wieder für ein paar
Stunden in den Schatten und dann nach
drinnen und so kann man die draußen Zeit
dann jeden Tag ein bisschen erhöhen bis
sie dann nach ungefähr einer Woche
abgehärtet sind und nach draußen ins
Beet umziehen können daran also immer
denken auch bei den Pflanzen die ihr
jetzt schon Vormittag mal nach draußen
pflanzt so Zucchini ist beschriftet ich
packe dieses Anzug Tray wieder weg weil
die kann man hier einfach so groß sind
ich habe die Zucchini Pflanzen in die
großen gesät weil die nicht so gerne
umgetopft werden aber die restlichen
Gemüsepflanzen die wir noch im Haus
vorziehen können wieder in die kleinen
scheiße jetzt kommt eins der schönsten
Gemüse im Gemüsegarten das hier ist der
Zier cool da habe ich überhaupt keine
Sorten Empfehlung weil ich glaube da
gibt's auf Deutsch gar keine Sorten oder
falls falls das nicht stimmt könnt ihr
mich ja korrigieren und viele Leute
wissen nicht dass man den auch essen
kann also der wird ja oft in Blumenläden
verkauft einfach so als wie so eine
Primel als Zierpflanze man kann den aber
essen der schmeckt auch relativ lecker
also vielleicht nicht so gut wie so ein
Weißkohl aber dafür sieht er eben hübsch
und bunt aus und die kann man eben auch
den ganzen Winter über ernten und ein
weiteres Wintergemüse ist der Rosenkohl
ich mache das jetzt einfach ich mache
das jetzt einfach wer weiß vielleicht
finde ich irgendwie eine Lösung und was
für ein Winter ohne eigenen Rosenkohl da
habe ich sowieso Respekt vor weil wenn
wir umziehen werde ich wahrscheinlich
die erste Zeit wahrscheinlich ungefähr
ein Jahr lang Gemüse kaufen müssen im
Laden ich würde mir gern die Zeit nehmen
den Garten erst richtig schön zu machen
bevor ich da loslege das wird
wahrscheinlich bis zum nächsten Frühjahr
dauern wenn ich dann erst anfange sind
die ersten Sachen vielleicht ab Mai
erntereif aber dann auch nur so Sachen
wie Salat und Spinat und erst im
nächsten Juli werde ich dann so richtig
viel ernten können juni fängst du schon
so an und im Juli ist dann die große
ernteschwämme das heißt ich werde
wahrscheinlich ein Jahr gar keine Gemüse
selbst versorgerin sein das ist der
Groninger das ist meine Liebste
rosenkohlsorte die Gurke könnt ihr jetzt
vorziehen habe ich letzten Monat schon
gemacht deswegen reicht mir das erstmal
ich habe jetzt so viele Gurkenpflanzen
das passt dann den Kürbis ist ja auch
eng verwandt mit Gurke und Zucchini und
den Salat und dass ich den nicht aussehe
liegt einfach daran dass ich alles Salat
Saatgut im Garten habe und mein Garten
ist nicht direkt am Haus und ich habe
vergessen das Herz zu holen und deswegen
gibt's kein Salat in der Ansicht auch
wenn ich eigentlich welchen aussehen
würde weil bei Salat ist es z.B total
sinnvoll jeden Monat was auszusehen weil
er so schnell wächst weil man den so
schnell aufessen kann wir haben deswegen
sehe ich den eigentlich jeden Monat aus
und die sollten die ich aussehen würde
wären jetzt die Sonne Summertime und
Piraten weil das Gute Sorten für den
Sommer sind und wir gehen jetzt raus in
starten und dann zeige ich euch was ihr
da sowohl Aussehen als auch welche
Pflanzen die ihr vorgezogen oder gekauft
habt ihr jetzt nach draußen setzen könnt
bevor ich irgendwas in meinem Garten
aussehe gehe ich immer einmal mit dem
Rechen über das Beet und reche alle
groben Teile von der Erde hier liegt zum
Beispiel ein bisschen Stroh noch von den
Enden ein paar gröbere Hackschnitzel die
kommen hier alle auf den Weg dann locker
ich die Erde so ein bisschen
oberflächlich auf wirklich nur so die
obersten Zentimeter und nur mit dem
Rechen und ohne das zu wenden einfach
nur falls sich mal gröbere Klumpen
gebildet haben dass sie sich wieder
lösen weil ihr wisst ja ich gärtnere
ohne Umgraben wir haben die Beete mit
Kompost angelegt so dass die Erde die
oben auf liegt sowieso super fein
krümelig und locker ist das macht es uns
bei den Auszeiten natürlich sehr leicht
und deswegen ist so wird auch ganz
schnell vorbereitet und je nachdem was
ich anbauen möchte also z.B bei
Wurzelgemüse Mais oder Kohl hat sich das
bei mir bewährt gehe ich dann noch mal
mit der doppelgabe
das Bild drüber und locker den Boden
noch ein bisschen tiefer auf Steine wenn
ihr Steine findet immer raus sammeln
wenn ihr Unkraut in euren Beeten habt
und das ist auch ein großer Vorteil wenn
man nicht umgräbt dann hat man so gut
wie keinen Unkraut dann macht das vorher
raus dann können wir auch sehen und ich
habe euch ja gesagt dass ich hier Bohnen
aussehen möchte und das verwundert jetzt
vielleicht ein paar wenn das Video
Anfang Mai online geht vor den
Eisheiligen bei Bohnen nämlich auch
frostempfindlich sind aber ich werde
eine Sorte aussehen die mit Frost ganz
gut klar kommt so hier haben wir jetzt
die eisbone die kommt jetzt ins Bett
hier steht drauf ab Ende April geht das
schon mit der Auszeit und dann Mitte Mai
also direkt nach den Eisheiligen könnt
ihr dann auch alle anderen Bohnen nach
draußen sehen egal ob es Stangenbohnen
oder Buschbohnen sind und da ist meine
Lieblingssorte die purple Pipi das ist
eine lila farbene Torte habt ihr schon
mal euren eigenen Chicoree angebaut das
kann man jetzt auch machen wenn ihr im
Winter Chicoree ernten wollt dann bringt
jetzt die Samen direkt im Beat aus
Mangold könnt ihr jetzt auch direkt ins
Beet aussehen und für Karotten ist jetzt
auf jeden Fall auch noch gut Zeit dabei
müsst ihr daran denken dass die Samen
sehr sehr lange brauchen um zu keimen
und man die ganz lange im Beat feucht
halten muss Pastinaken könnt ihr jetzt
auch noch sehen dass es aber wirklich
höchster Eisenbahn weil die wirklich
auch sehr langsam wachsen ein Kandidat
der richtig schnell wächst ist das
Radieschen dafür ist jetzt auch noch
Zeit den Rettich den könnt ihr jetzt
auch sehen ist auch ein richtig schnell
wachsendes Gemüse ich sehr jetzt z.B
Rettich aus damit ich dann im Herbst
machen kann ein Gemüse das wenig Leute
kennen das aber auch ganz gut schmeckt
ist der hirschhornweg Gericht den kann
man jetzt aussehen und für die Rote
Beete ist jetzt auch ein perfekter
Aussatz seit Punkt da liebe ich es zwei
verschiedene Sorten anzubauen einmal
eine geringelte die heißt Tonda
wahrscheinlich spreche ich es vollkommen
falsch aus und eine komplett rote z.B
die robuschka oder die Kirche es gibt
auch weizenförmige die hat dann noch
eine größeren Ertrag weil die eben noch
eine längere Knolle bildet auch wenn die
dann anders aussieht als normale rote
Beete Rucola könnt ihr jetzt aussehen
und alle möglichen Salate ich würde bei
den Salaten wirklich drauf achten dass
es eine relativ schoss feste Sorte ist
weil die Richtung Sommer dann schnell in
die Blüte gehen und bitter werden beim
spinat ist es genau die gleiche
Geschichte da würde ich jetzt die Sorte
gammason aussehen das ist nämlich eine
sehr schoss feste Sorte es gibt ja die
sogenannte spinatlücke die man im Sommer
hat wo man relativ wenig erntet weil
alle Spinat Pflanzen schießen und klar
schießt der Amazon irgendwann auch aber
eben später als die anderen Sorten
Zucchini könnt ihr jetzt direkt ins
betteln haben wir eben schon erwähnt und
Zwiebeln ganz genau so außerdem könnt
ihr jetzt auch Erbsen aussehen die
brauchen immer einen Rankhilfe ich habe
hier deswegen dieses Netz aufgespannt
man kann sonst auch Zweige in die Erde
stecken ich habe schon ich glaube im
Februar diese Erbsen ausgesät die jetzt
hier wachsen und ich sehe gerade dass da
zwischen den einzelnen Pflanzen
irgendwie noch so Lücken sind so keine
Erbse aufgegangen ist entweder weil ein
Vogel die Erbse geklaut hat oder weil
die eine nicht gut gekeimt hat oder
warum auch immer auf jeden Fall werde
ich jetzt einfach in die Lücken noch mal
neu Erbsen nachsäen und normalerweise
baue ich am liebsten die Sorten Ambrosia
als Zuckererbse und Ambassador als
markerbse an also mag erbsen sind die
Erbsen die man zum Beispiel dann als
Gemüse ist wo man richtig schöne runde
Kugeln hat und nicht die ganze Schote
essen möchte aber ich habe mir jetzt
gedacht ich selber eine blaue Erbse
dazwischen die heißt blau Schocker weil
das bestimmt hübsch aussieht wenn
zwischendrin immer mal eine blaue
erbsenpflanze hochkommen ich glaube an
der Stelle bin ich tatsächlich drauf
geleitet auf die kleinen Erbsen
Pflänzchen weil hier sind gar keine
gekommen an einer Stelle als wir dieses
Netz hier fotografiert haben für den
wurzelwerkshop ja haben will die Fotos
gemacht und ich hatte dabei schon das
Gefühl dass mein Garten arg in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird und ja ich
glaube ich habe die Platte getrampelt
nach dem Eisheiligen könnt ihr dann auch
Gurken direkt sehen und Kürbisse und
auch alle Maissorten also Zuckermais
aber auch meist den ihr vielleicht zum
Brot backen oder für Polenta anbauen
wollte ja was sprechen wir mal darüber
welche Gemüse Pflanzen also egal ob man
die in der Gärtnerei gekauft hat oder
selber im Haus vorgezogen hat man dann
jetzt im Mai nach draußen setzen kann
und das ist auch wieder ganz wichtig
dass wir daran denken dass der Mai ja
zweigeteilt ist vor den Eisheiligen
könnt ihr Sachen wie Salat und das ganze
Kohlgemüse also Weißkohl Rotkohl wir
singen Rosenkohl Blumenkohl Brokkoli was
gibt's noch Chinakohl das hier ist z.B
Chinakohl Spitzkohl den Kohlrabi die
könnt ihr jetzt alle nach draußen
Pflanzen auch vor den Eisheiligen das
haben wir auch schon im März gemacht und
im April gemacht und auch könnt ihr
jetzt pflanzen ihr könnt jetzt
Stangensellerie und Knollensellerie
Pflanzen Neuseeländer Spinat falls ihr
den noch nicht ausprobiert habt das ist
so eine Ranken das Gemüse dass man wie
Spinat essen kann und auch Zwiebeln
könnt ihr jetzt nach draußen Pflanzen
egal ob ihr aus dem Haus vorgezogen habt
oder ob ihr Steckzwiebeln anbaut sowie
die hier wenn ihr die pflanzt dann denkt
daran dass die Spitze Seite immer nach
oben zeigen muss und die stumpfe Seite
nach unten weil man sieht das hier schon
da unten kommen nämlich die Wurzeln raus
und hier oben kommt dann das Zwiebelgrün
noch raus und wenn ihr ausseht oder
pflanzt dann habt ihr immer auch die
Mischkultur im Hinterkopf weil ja
bestimmte Gemüsepflanzen nebeneinander
wachsen sollten und andere sich nicht
gut vertragen es gibt also Freunde und
Feinde in der gemüsewelt die sich z.B
gegenseitig die Schädlinge und die
Krankheiten vom Leib halten können die
auch das Aroma voneinander beeinflussen
können also Tomaten und Basilikum sind
so ein schönes Beispiel die schmecken
beide besser wenn man die nebeneinander
anbaut und dann gibt es Pflanzen wie die
Tomate und die Kartoffeln die einfach
sehr ähnliche Krankheiten bekommen oder
eigentlich die gleichen Krankheiten
bekommen und die man immer möglichst
weit voneinander entfernt anbauen sollte
weil man sonst bei beiden Kulturen eine
ganz schlechte Ernte haben könnte hatte
ich mal in einem Jahr in meinem Garten
das war überhaupt nicht schön also die
Mischkultur immer beachten ich habe auch
eine Mischkultur Tabelle auf meiner
Website die ihr euch runterladen könnt
die verlinke ich euch mal hier oben und
im obersten angepinnten Kommentar die
könnt ihr euch auf dem Handy abspeichern
oder ausdrucken damit ihr die immer beim
Aussehen und Pflanzen parat habt und
wenn ihr wissen wollt was im Mai im
Garten sonst noch ansteht also neben den
ausseiten gibt's ja noch eine Menge
andere Sachen zu tun dann schaut gerne
mal da drüben vorbei der verlinke ich
euch nämlich ein Video in dem ich euch
mitnehmen in den Garten und ich zeige
welche Gartenarbeiten im Mai anstehen
und sonst geht raus macht die Welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns
nächste Woche wieder oder übernächste
Woche mal gucken mit einem neuen Video
macht's gut bis dann tschüss